the old and frail and terribly scared
are still being brought to Safety in
their thousands
[Music]
there's a grateful kiss for her Rescuers
many of these elderly folk lived alone
with their pets
others were confined to their
Wheelchairs and unable to leave
themselves
it's okay it's okay they reassure
yevgenia as she clings to them she's
partially blind and clearly confused and
terrified as she's handed over to her
younger relative who immediately
consoles her
we're all out she tells the octogenarian
we came back for you
senior U.N officials say this
humanitarian crisis will have grave and
far-reaching consequences
many of these people left with barely
any of their possessions
their homes are destroyed and now
there's little Safe Drinking Water
they're lucky if they've managed to grab
some soggy IDs on the way out
among those who managed to make it to
Harrison City a group who fled from the
russian-controlled area
Katarina is amongst them and in her 84
years she's not experienced anything
like this barbarity
the rescued are now extending the same
kindness to those still in need
and this group can't quite believe that
they've made it
the group is still traumatized and at
least two were in their 80s they're all
so relieved and overwhelmed with emotion
the current was so powerful she says we
barely made it
they were surrounded by Russian troops
and tell us of beaches being bombed as
they tried to flee to Ukrainian
territory and how the Russian soldiers
tried to steal their boats
when we were in dachi all our boats had
been sunk she told us and they were
looting on summer houses and our boat
engines they were taking everything the
guys just managed to save our two boats
a huge area at the battlefield is now
submerged with levels Rising 11 feet in
just 24 hours and no sign of it receding
just yet the Ukrainian president has
spoken of enough fresh water now being a
real concern and drones are being used
to drop supplies to those now surrounded
by water
all these trees are submerged the houses
the whole of the basement and the first
floor has gone
and you can hear the sound as they're
still trying to defend themselves the
bus stop where people used to to stop
and and try and get buses is now pretty
much completely submerged
amphibious vehicles like the sherp with
its specialized inflatable tires are
being used to get through these Waters
and there are scores of volunteers
working alongside soldiers and police
trying to pull to safety as many people
as possible
turn around mccola tells him it'll be
easier
there are at least four people left in
this block with those in the lower
levels moving in with Neighbors in the
flats above were you scared being
stranded there overnight
yes it was scary eor tells us I was
afraid water just came in and you
couldn't do anything
The Rescuers have got their work cut out
for them
they're told by others that they're
still a blind woman trapped in her home
further on
is anyone alive they Shout
yes comes a pink voice I'm on the fourth
floor
they ask her if she's alone she is but
she has ten cats and a dog they urge her
to stay still and radio for help
by the time she reaches dry land she's
exhausted
and very tearful she's already been
through so much
there are a lot of animals still being
found to many of the rescued humans they
have been their Lifeline in this
protracted War
the Russians are still insisting they're
not responsible for this catastrophic
disaster as the ukrainians scramble to
save as many creatures however tiny as
possible
there are dire predictions of just how
badly this will hit the country long
term not just household pets but their
livestock their Farm exports
agricultural stocks will all be badly
impacted too and the consequences of the
dam burst is likely to be felt for years
to come Alex Crawford Sky News in
southern Ukraine foreign